hello and welcome to poke Friday good fo
Friday I guess ah there you go
hello it's Good Friday if that is your
sort of thing for me it's just the work
day because I'm here at the Melbourne
International Comedy Festival in fact
it's opening night so if you are hearing
this since on the Friday and you're
looking for a night to come come tonight
because you know the press are in and if
you come and it's full and you're laugh
really loud
they'll probably just ignore that and
give me a terrible review now I really
love this show in fact look comment I
say this all the time but you know I'm
guess I'm what if I did not think it
then I shouldn't be doing the show in
the first place but I love this show
this is my favorite show that I've ever
done and I think the reason is mostly
because I've just got to talk about
Australia in our own country a bit which
is something I have heard and kind of
steered away from in the last kind of
five or six years as I've tried to make
my material more international but last
year I did a political show and some of
you heard me talk about that and it just
kind of really inspired me that there
was some things back home that I was
incredibly interested in and some of the
bits in the show even have grown out of
that show I touched a little on what
happened to Adam Goodes back then but I
didn't have the words or the jokes to
really fully Express the point I was
trying to make but now I do and I'm very
proud of that routine in particular it's
probably the heart of the show to me
it's where the show started and and what
the rest of the show is kind of about
was that we had an instance in Australia
where the bullies won and I didn't love
it and so I wanted to write a piece of
material about that and then that grew
into an entire show I started in
Adelaide with about a 50/50 shot was
about fifty sort of you know stuff there
50 percent stuff that I thought would
travel internationally about 52 percent
Australian and I thought that was a good
mix and by the end of Adelaide well I
mean at 60 70 minutes of Australian
stuff and there's a quick little
international story at the end but it is
mostly an Australian show and I've been
loving doing that it's just been great
to be able to muck around in an area
that I feel very passionate about but
also that you know obviously that is my
culture and is my life and the world
that I live in in the country that has
been most important to me and speaking
to the audience who are from that
country it's just been a great
experience for me and to use the skills
I have now that I didn't have sort of
five or six years ago when I stopped
talking about these things I mean it's
just been a real pleasure to do the show
so please come out and say the show it's
on for a month in Melbourne it is on
Wednesday through Sunday so fewer shows
this year
we are gonna run our tickets basically
there are less tickets on sale this year
than we sold last year so please don't
wait until the end and then complain to
me and say hey there's no tickets left
and I'll say well why didn't you come on
the first Thursday when there was so
anyway that would be great
Sydney Opera House that's coming up
really soon that's within the next two
weeks
April the seventh Thursday night first
show it's getting close to sold out but
second show still plenty of tickets
available and we'd love to fill them
both up Justin Hamilton doing support
and yeah like I said one night only in
Sydney so if you want to catch the show
in Sydney this year you've got to see it
on April the 7th there's ten the Opera
House what about that what else what
else what else oh oh gotta tell you
about this I went on sale today the live
tofo at the Melbourne International
Comedy Festival is on sale and already
half sold out it's amazing the support
we've had for that show we moved to a
much bigger venue and I'm glad we did
because even on this first day we sold
double amount of the tickets that would
have filled the old room so thank you so
much for the support and I would say if
you want to come along to that get in
really quick because that will sell out
definitely before we do it I would say
at this rate either that or this 500
people who want to see it and then
no-one else does
just see and a half empty for the next
two weeks but I'm hoping that won't be
the case we have got a superstar lineup
at that thing by the way Daniel sauce is
gonna come and do something Lindsey Webb
Justin Hamilton Felicity Ward possibly
Celia piccola if she's around said she
will do it we've got a Jen Kirkman
hologram it's all hosted by John dates
and we have a very special guest star of
our sleep that we are not going to
mention until the night but I'm just
telling you if you like this podcast
then you're gonna like the guess that's
all I'll say okay all right what else
Perth that's the first week of May so
buy tickets to that oh and my all Asia
is where Gareth Reynolds who is today's
guest on photo op will be doing my
support I think that is on Thursday the
21st or something like that of April so
I'll let you know when that is on up and
about and you can grab some tickets to
that as well all right that's the plugs
I hope you have a great day I hope you
enjoyed this episode there will be a new
table on Sunday check out the regular
tops that are now coming out there's
been regular will lhasa fees is a great
new one with Tom Ballard which I really
love doing the one before is probably
the one that's had the most reaction of
anyone I've ever done with Usher
Ginsburg
so if you check that out yet he's
amazingly honest about his struggles
with alcohol and anxiety and a whole
bunch of things and it was just a really
fun chat and of course Charlie and I now
have an AFL football podcast that just
sort of thing it's called two guys one
cup one episode up but we'll try Joe new
one next week after the first round of
40 so heaps of podcasts and you will
hear a discussion about me and all my
podcasts on this very episode so I hope
you enjoy it and talk to you again
really soon cheers guys the farming
episode of fofo is classified m.a it
contains some course language some
nudity drunk references a sex scene time
travel terrible Batman impersonations at
Charlie Clausen pronounced Clausen
shaped whole and mild course language fo
fum advisors that the program is not
suitable for persons under the age of 15
and minors must be accompanied by an
adult guardian or priest this is John
deke speaking
hello and welcome to photo op I'm Will
Anderson and returning a guest Charlie
cloths and Gareth Reynolds is here we
actually just recording this episode
after we recorded a previous one you
heard but that was probably weeks ago so
so timeline this is like about why I'm
trying it what I'm trying to do now
Gareth is that I'm trying to put out
flow 5 on a Friday
right we'll also be on our way both
Friday for Friday right velocity
Wednesday and right and then toe for
Sunday interesting Sunday silent T sorry
in Sunday surely like putting it yeah
exactly like Tonga exactly the who who
doesn't know what you're talking about
when you say that exactly
SETI yeah exactly the foreign ones that
have the tier anyway so on Sunday
because that's when it used to come out
right it doesn't mean that those
podcasts come out every week on those
day on those days but it means that it
when they come out they're gonna come
out on those days cuz rated to get some
structure yes into my life but fo FOP is
the one that's easy
so this one five Friday so it's always
full flow from their sole proprietor
it's hard to say for Friday Friday but
IIF I say to give so I did not realize
what we did not realize I've taken off
in between the last podcast that we did
and this podcast and we've just started
I've taken off my hoodie yes and it is
revealed something that you spotted
which I did not spawn at the time but
you are wearing a beer hat not a not one
that has beers on the side of it I
should point out that one do I thought
that'd be weird to wear I think I've
conjured a Timmy
let's podcast baby yeah take a hit of
this smoke this [ __ ] we'll get to it
when we get to it
Gareth's you've a skateboard Garrett's
wearing on I'm podcasting least
reputation yeah and a foam figure to
boot number one I don't know what I'm
routing floor of it yeah that's how do
you merchandise faux foam finger foam
fingers for foam four fingers it's a
foam finger product TGIF
it's do gif I have cube [ __ ] finger
sounds like a very like shape version of
the James Bond finger s no mister
spawned I expect you to recognize I'm
number one that's it now you can go I'm
winning baby or it sounds like a 99 cent
store tampon ripoff get a foam finger it
might work nope
don't use it while camping not for
camping use this has bear attack written
all over it fun fingers they might work
not for camping not for camping let's do
not camp with these in fine print I said
really quick at the end
fine fine fingers are not meant to use
for camping fun fingers they might work
do not use while camping terrified did
you watch any of the commercials while
speaking of beer we mentioned the Super
Bowl last time were together because
when we recorded this it was close to
the Super Bowl
yes seems like weird you know five weeks
later which still talking about listen
that's life and space game so Gareth is
wearing a PBR perhaps Blue Ribbon B hat
yeah and I am wearing a perhaps Blue
Ribbon t-shirt yes it was revealed
together we are the paps Bros the PBR
boy is the Blue Boys yes we're the faux
perverse
yeah it really does look like we're in
like like we are sponsoring and tired I
just like to come home crack open a
suite PBR let the day just pass me by I
mean it really does feel like I seen
from a James Bond movie yeah with all
the random products like this James Bond
like PBR No - venti macchiatos listen
let's talk about the plan thanks for my
foot long no problem they were able to
make that because the generator which is
Duracell the number one battery in the
nation made it during this emergency but
that would be a great moment in a James
Bond saying where he goes down to like Q
make sure you've got your cell batteries
Jerris LJ's
it's too valuable to lose energizer or
never ready it's not a juror cell it
simply won't work you know what I always
say Q at time is of the essence let me
just get this out if it's not a Duracell
you'll be in Deraa Hell right all right
well anyway there's that what else
everyone's just a bunch of D batteries
of here they have really been obsessed
the Duracell lately honestly in putting
them in everything every smoke detectors
up to code I could assure you that
there's no worry of that James James
hello James
Lettie have I liked the idea that on the
first of like July every year q replaces
yeah the batteries in every secret
gadget now's not a good time doing my
replacement come back tomorrow you
suspect that I didn't you useful I did
yeah yeah so what I see because I think
I heard you on comedy film nerds talking
about spectre and saying that it was you
thought it was okay it was the bomb no I
liked it I thought I thought that
Skyfall was great I really really liked
Skyfall and and I thought Spectre was
good you know but yeah the action scenes
are so entertaining I think those are
like worth it for me that's why I'll see
any of those Bond films with him because
I think those action scenes are so good
but uh but yeah I don't know
at the end of it like the truth is it's
it's funny because like this character
or like films in general have sort of
evolved now to the point where you think
about like The Dark Knight series like
that was kind of the first time where a
movie where the superhero character had
like depth and flaws and all this stuff
and it worked and people went and saw it
so then you know now I think there's
this new kind of version of James Bond
like I was watching the Pierce Brosnan
ones there was some marathon like two
months ago and I was just I just jumped
in and I was watching them and I was
like these are terrible they are so like
they're just they're just it's not good
it's just it feels like very contrived
it's just not now there's an element of
like realism to the bond character and
the bond world like the way that it
works it's still crazy and the [ __ ] that
goes on is crazy but there's a little
more there's a little less magic to the
whole thing the Pierce Brosnan ones are
absurd like his disguises are insane the
stuff that he does is it believe it or
not even for James Bond is too
unbelievable and and they're just not
it's not nearly as entertaining as the
ones now so I think the ones now have
this like yeah there's just kind of more
depth to the character the character is
different and but I do think also that
you could lose some of the things that
are always part like he still has to
like [ __ ] three girls a movie oh you
know and it's it's like it's kind of
like this to-do list it's kind of like
this barometer of as you're going
through like he's [ __ ] the third
alright we're getting to the climax here
something big is gonna happen now right
no but it's just that to me is like a
little like maybe we're holding on to
this relic that we don't really need
anymore
like you don't really and there's
something about that that it feels just
like a bit more gross than it used to
yeah like in the old days you were like
oh it was the best James Bond movie had
sex with three women two of them died
yeah yeah and they yeah she got harpoon
through the heart right doesn't matter
though James is fine drugs will be fine
oh yeah I mean it was the day of her
husband's funeral
yeah and he really kind of wordlessly
pushed her against the wall yeah
away with her after a couple drinks
force sees why she did say no I mean
she's on record as saying no literally
yeah but you know a great movie great
movie
great set great three awkward shower
scenes it was early on so she died
she's dead obviously she was the first
one yeah they seemed to really get it
off - I was shocked they met in the hot
tub
I mean he has he does have a media
connection to his people that's the
thing about James um you know what he is
he falls hard and then he's gone yeah
it's pretty much all or nothing
you're gonna he's the king of eight our
relationships right it must be hard it
must be a real turn peeing because like
just based on his record like the fact
that like James Bond is essentially one
of those people like you know the
counter-argument was always like yeah I
have the right to my gun but yeah but if
your gun if your hobby started like you
know killing people yeah like whatever
I'm into like you know for watching Lots
is they worked out than watching lost
something they was like killing hates of
paper right happy like well you know
what like I always liked watching what
loss but that was when it wasn't killing
people live yeah it's almost like James
Bond is like the ring but as a man like
if your daughter comes home and is like
I met the greatest guy do you know James
Bond they'd be like you don't see him
again if we're burying you underground
when you say James Bond's ring yeah
anybody sees James Bond's ring did you
see his ring you have six days maximum
anything outside of that will be a
goddamn miracle what you idiot James
Bond has slept with over three billion
women he's the king of the eight-hour
recording them let me guess you [ __ ]
in the shower right right yeah yeah yeah
you're dead you're dead for sure I'll
bring in a doctor you need yeah that's
yeah you'll die yeah get out of here
doctor goodbye obvious they see people
like they think he's left a note but
it's really just like they're legally
binding don't you yeah dividing your
life who are you I'm a notary yep
whenever you're ready I think that
everything if there's anything you want
to do just make it in pen right now
I'll have it really wake up there's
somebody measuring you yeah sorry I'm
the coffin I just they say come in this
thing a medium give you a little room
play around it yeah what are you sorry
about that sorry that you [ __ ] James
Bond elbow anyway
you knew the deal right literally the
biggest killer it goes it goes heart
disease is a mobile device death [ __ ]
James Bond those are the top three more
people die per year [ __ ] James Bond
then a kill by terrorists then cancer
AIDS and terrorism come on if those
three [ __ ] and had a baby James Bond
sex would still kill more people I mean
but this is the thing like the say 80%
of the women you had sex with died look
within a wake of you having sex with it
essentially this is you do what this is
early on you're like oh well you know it
kind of sounds like Cosby numbers right
yeah it like if it suddenly came out
like there's your take on Jack oh my
gosh mom we haven't seen before well you
know what the big story is I know he's
like saves a lot of like he's not a lot
of cool things but you know there's like
80% of the women that he [ __ ] died
with no way crimes bar D is for death
right yeah I said you can have someone
like Ziggy that opening theme cuz D is
for death I just think it's like that's
a pattern yeah and maybe after a while
you put your [ __ ] away right yeah I got
you'd be like why just can't yeah
like even if you're like well you know I
mean I bet you know you'd probably blow
at that point there probably someone
online who you could go to and be like
will my dick kill her doctor what do you
think like I could say certainly that
75% she will survive you'd be like Jim
what do you you like do you want to know
I mean like I said I've lost three
fiance's to this guy today I should be
very clear I'm looking to settle down if
that's not coming across I fall haha I
fall hard for her I have Bond isms
I might come on a little too strong I
gotta be honest with you if I was unlike
the Bonjour people would be like 'hey
Stewie's 2 for life
I have crazy eyes that's the way God
made me nothing and I've had a bad run I
mean [ __ ] me once shame on me but [ __ ]
me twice shame on you because the new
bad [ __ ] me twice shame on you shame on
you I mean it's a like that's a
something you've got to tell your
partner about like I mean if you've got
an STD an STI or yeah like then it's
obviously you've got to tell your
partner about it if you're having like a
you know one of these sort of one
because he doesn't know these people's
sexual history now like you know it
doesn't know what they've been doing or
like you know I bet he's got some pretty
cool gadget tree in the condom though if
you use you know what that's probably
what it is
who's like yeah put this in our bottom a
little bit James she will go crazy
q what's going use a Duracell right as I
was saying before James the only thing
for the bum waggle is a Duracell all
right Q this has gone far enough
right sorry just get so lonely down here
you know James one just sits conceiving
all day makes a man wonder alone James
how is he
God how does he keep only one door it's
not mm-hmm anyway you complete me
Duracell I'm still here James hello
didn't thought you I was wondering where
you'd been look at that I wasn't I don't
have oh goodness
well I guess he would be like cuz he is
if he's like having sex with that many
women yeah you'd imagine that he's
probably dropping in the queue for some
you know yeah very lace some sort of
super condom yeah but you know something
that vibrates set off ways watch yeah
right yeah this button twice and it'll
begin to vibrate James right
she won't know what hit her cuz I mean
maybe that's
because he's doing a lot of like you
know questions ask [ __ ] like I mean
he's got to be using protest something
yeah it's gotta be yeah cuz otherwise
he's just read order with unless they
unless his government agency has a cure
for everything and he comes in he's a
thumping razor blades like open your
mouth James yeah we are gonna make that
go away thank God
last few days have been terrible yes
James maybe wrap it up next time anyway
that's so lonely down here that's
essentially the plot to limitless James
Bond is just horrible coffin my [ __ ]
burns for God's sake some point you must
learn a lesson open your mouth
put out your hand oh my god that's all
gone now got AIDS again well for God's
sake James open your mouth open it so
lonely I thought with the Bond film that
IIIi felt it was a bit of a weird mix of
like it occasionally it felt like they
were trying to do a bit of that
old-school Pierce Brosnan or like yeah
you know Roger Moore sort of like you
know kind of more funny bond or whatever
and I did I like I yeah you Daniel Craig
bond is just you have you saying did you
see the trailer for the new Jason Bourne
film that they during the Superbowl like
that whatever many seconds of that yeah
seems like more exciting than the whole
of that James Bond film to me
yeah I agree it would it really I mean
you know there a lot needs to go right
like I mean it must be a really [ __ ]
hard thing to write because you are like
how do you walk this line of what the
tone of your movie really is because you
do live in reality but such a heightened
reality that like what really are the
rules but yeah the last one it just
didn't feel like there was you know
again I mean it's really what interlaces
those key set peace moments how good is
that thing and in Spectre it wasn't as
good as Skyfall you know and for the
most part the
Daniel Craig ones do a really good job
of having a good Drive and if it has a
good villain then you're like oh that's
a good Bond movie yeah you know I
thought um what the what's his name
Christoph Waltz yeah that was I didn't
think he was great who was the one
before in Skyfall let's just call him
marijuana because that's who we blame
[ __ ] I wish I could remember his name
it's a Xavier bar down I in my head what
I wanted to say was llamado tour I
thought that too as soon as I had that
in there you know as soon as you've got
like one thing that you yeah is wrong
yeah but it's like you stick you're
stuck to it like it's definitely three
words yeah definitely no this guy it's
definitely not that but this is all you
can think of now that's all I got yeah
he was good I mean he's very good and
that was and that was like a really
weird sort of like villain you know it
was like that that was way more
interesting christopher waltz you know I
think he won't through it good night
ladies are I day of Friday a podcast and
podcasting didn't go out on top
necessarily way but it is over
something will Anderson and Gareth
Reynolds called it at a strange moment
should we call it yeah I think we're
good here I think we're good Marc Maron
not upset Adam Carolla by now
I mean at some stage I guess podcasting
might die because I mean it's like the
the like I guess the me the medium is
like available now and so I guess people
will just because everyone's got a show
now like I mean this is the interesting
thing about the world of podcasting like
in YouTube and all those sort of things
and what they've opened up to people is
the idea that it's the democratization
of entertainment you know like I mean
even if people stopped listening to
podcasts like will people keep making
them I guess you will now because you
can yeah I think you will I mean I you
know I mean if you think about it a
little bit like a YouTube channel like
you know there's people who are not
having much success on a YouTube channel
but will still put it out there because
it is something
you know something you're working on I
think you're constantly developing it
your mind in one way or another whether
it's connected to reality I mean the the
interesting about podcasts I reckon is
when they finish because like with the
television show or with anything like
that no one really expects like even a
radio show yeah that expects that you'll
do it forever there are there are some
people who yeah those lucky few who end
up doing it forever yeah but most people
go into one of those things going okay
well at best I'll probably do this for
like yeah you know four or five years or
whatever but with a podcast like
podcasting like essentially the slogan
should be there was no reason to start
so why is there a recently stopped yeah
it's very true like you know some things
have natural ending yeah like you know
you wouldn't like after the office I
mean the office did [ __ ] you know
certain episodes yeah okay office and
we're like we're done yeah yeah if you
do [ __ ] 500 podcasts and people
though would you stop doing your vodka
I felt like it was getting up it was
yeah whatever though but that's podcast
I guess this isn't doing it okay okay so
when you're running out of [ __ ] to talk
about what else [ __ ] I think that might
be everything I wanted to say so yeah
you get to something like something
really passionate the thoughts we said
everything I'm gonna do a quick 21 at
one on ampersands but then I'll be out
little ampersand on call hey everybody
welcome to Ambur cast this is where I
tear apart ever since which again is
such a lazy way of saying and right so
this is will ampersand Allison ampersand
I finally ran out of will pardon so I
move on to the last night which is an
ampersand ampersand the ampersand is in
here I'm faux Friday efforts Anderson
you're sponsored by ampersand but
there's one caveat will we want you to
call yourself will ampere Sanderson I
mean to be honest that's not too bad
great welcome aboard yeah get him the
cash guys now I have
we recently had a baby boy so could I
call the business will amber Sanderson
and Sun guys get your hands out shake
his hand shake this winners hand okay
shake his goddamn hand hopefully some
talent rubs off on you jerk on you love
it will we love you and we love it and
we love your son and / Sanders Sanderson
he's got a kid for Sandra Granderson
he's really good friends with irons
earrings kids so it's ampersand Steve
Sanderson he loves fried chicken so he's
gonna be will amber Colonel Sanders
Sanderson yeah he's very political so
he's Bernie Sanders sniffing around it
if you're Sanders you didn't get a shout
out
sorry about that or The Simpsons
neighbor will Sanderson - Ned - Flanders
Simpson yeah like finishing like going
okay we're done now this is the I mean
it's been weird for me in my podcasting
world in it like you know Toph op
Charlie and I like that yeah the podcast
has no reason to be like podcasts now
which I like I like you know a lot of
podcasts I listen to have like and I
like I love green guide letters or I
like will listen to the dole up or I
like you know these things that you're
like oh well this is the purpose and
there's something wonky which is like
political podcast or like I love junk
time IFL podcast but they all have
specific purposes right to be podcast
yeah
whereas toe fault was just like Charlie
and I hanging out yeah you know and so
and then that became this faux fault
which is now like to be honest I mean
when we've done like 240 of these or
whatever so this is actually the like
the big one is the one but this is real
like the but it's fine that's like the
sidekick that's done better than the
original I guess I'd project that went
better than the feature beating the
headliners yeah or is like when some guy
from some band like goes out and just
like like Phil Collins leaving Genesis
right they're like you're a drummer get
out of here but that's part of the thing
that I like about podcasts too though is
that they naturally develop and unfold
and there's just this sort of like
because it's very I think you know
audiences feel very connected to them I
think there is this way that like it's
almost like if your podcast is the sale
like what people think is the wind and
will like make you develop things the I
yes I'm Native American obviously but it
will it sort of likes things that are
throwaways to you become running jokes
or like things that just happen to
organically become you know I mean
there's many things on both both of our
podcasts that are just things that have
been sort of dictated by reaction so I
think there there's something so
interesting about when a podcast starts
as you and Charlie and then here you are
you know it's just it's interesting
yeah but the but the other thing about
it is because like it also because none
of them stop yeah if you add anything
you suddenly like find it so Charlie and
I four years of wanted to do this AFL
podcast right and like so this year like
we were gonna do that ofl podcast but
then we were like well we want to do
Toph up again regularly so I'm like okay
we should do Toph opera again regularly
right but of course in the meantime you
know build-up fofox to be this like
different thing as well I'm sorry I'm
like well I don't wanna stop doing photo
op I love doing that now so I'll keep
that guy and then I've got like well
Lhasa fear as well and then suddenly
you're a guy with a fork like crazy it's
like yeah it's like I have an imaginary
radio station yeah to me like it's like
I work like on this imaginary like I'm
essentially a kid in the backyard
playing [ __ ] radio with almost sure
it can be tried like none of it makes
any money like it's all like I'm
essentially with like a nail get even
just on airtime that's like literally a
day of my way just
record them yeah let alone edit them on
the internet and share like I'm like
taking a diet out of every [ __ ] week
minimum to run my imaginary radio
station look at that guy what the [ __ ]
are you doing seriously your imaginary
radio station I'm the boss and I'm on
all the shows advertising stop the
podcast I yell at no one dawg it's just
stuffed animals sitting in a chair I
have a little thing that says say er yes
enterprises hello
Charlie's Charlie's CFO yeah yeah just
it interviewing stuffed animals dogs
couch pillows I mean because that's the
thing a toothbrush I'm constantly
thinking you're in a lot of mouths I'm
constantly thinking about the podcast
ideas I'm like the one thing I know I
don't need in my life yes yeah I don't I
need less podcast what their gir they
are his amazing one like sometimes you
know you'll just if you're some week
she'll just shape up and you're just
doing a ton of podcast and it's one of
those things to where it's like you know
if I'll tell my mother like I've got a
go podcast all day and she's like but
who who is it for I'm like no never mind
I I notice it when I go home to Sydney
because when I do it here like I just
leave you know like you come in here
it's all set up
yeah like you know and it's a pretty
casual thing that I just do yeah
podcasting is a fine thing to do if no
one's watching yeah but what I've found
is if like there's someone else or
non-id casting watching apart ya know I
don't even mean just there but I mean
observing the thing actually happening
right I mean for all intents and
purposes today no one knows we're in
here podcast right like you know I don't
like the neighbors don't go all that
what are they going to do it like or
whatever there's no one else who's in
this house here who's like I'll go out
when your podcast yeah yeah yeah like
gauzy is one of those things that when
you're doing it by yourself you don't
think you're doing it a lot yeah but
when there's other people around you
like I've got to a podcast like how much
a podcast just a two more today and
there's one tomorrow and then like
really how's your imaginary radio
station going good it's good it's good
things are good with it that's
essentially what the CEO so I'm just
gonna go work on my imaginary radio
station have fun I wish they'd just
build a time machine
so sad hello welcome to the imaginary
radio station yeah it's like do you have
a hobby yeah I have an imaginary radius
I build trains and I also run a radio
station - go ahead
it's an Imagine radius it's like it's
like pretend it's like you know when a
kid gets oil on a tin can and talks into
it right just like what about but if
that kid gave himself for chars yeah
four different cans to use okay yeah
that boils it down huh uh-huh yeah um
worthy the Super Bowl commercials that's
what I wanted to talk to you about did
you watch any of the Super Bowl
commercials are you a person who enjoys
come now I think they used to be very
funny like Super Bowl commercials used
to be very funny and I feel like they're
just running on fumes for when they used
to be funny now because there are some
that are funny not through them but uh
but I didn't watch any of this here
because they're now what's happened is
it's become like anyone can get one so
you know it's a money thing it used to
be that there were kind of like I don't
even know what the real difference would
be but it seemed like ten years ago they
were much funnier and now they just kind
of run on the fumes of that time period
well I think what they do is they do
that classy thing like I know you won't
see that many [ __ ] celebrities like
at the Oscars right like there are so
many if you were a [ __ ] celebrity and
you know you weren't in a Super Bowl ad
yeah then you'd bring your [ __ ] agent
yeah so what they do is they pay for all
these celebrities and stuff instead of
like coming up with original or invent
ideas now like the ads were [ __ ] yeah
like the work this is meant to be like
the the biggest like you know
advertising matter of the world
yeah and it's they were [ __ ] this year I
thought they were really poor yeah it's
it is you know I mean they they again
they just they're so it's such a
competitor and by the way Snickers so if
you're listening we get it if we get
that we're good
yeah we good on that jar we're happy you
know feels like we peaked yeah how you
know how if you just report like it's
end the podcast Snickers the same joke
yeah it's the same joke guys it's not
getting better if it's not getting
better now
no but that's you know and that's tell
you know who might get better will them
too far no no Willem Dafoe's never made
anything better I don't think he's ever
eating a Snickers like Willem Dafoe
being Marilyn Martin like you're not
even trying anymore Marilyn Dafoe
Maryland if I mean if they if there'd
been anything there that clever in the
ass yeah I don't even know the ad you're
talking about ah it's one watch no but
it's the [ __ ] but it's the same bit
the same bit yeah you don't need to see
it no it it is I'll explain it to you
it's Willem Dafoe I like iconic Marilyn
Monroe you know dress over the great
yeah one seven years and she's taking
like so that's the same except it's
Willem Dafoe like being angry like why
would you even get a woman on a crate
with the you know what yeah why would
you even do this and it's like Marilyn
Marilyn yeah and it's the dude from
American Pie what's his name you Jane
levy or no huh yeah yeah yeah who's a
very funny guy yeah yeah s I think it's
him he's like the director right
whatever like you know it's like Meryl
now and have a Snickers you know you
know and then she has like he Willem
Dafoe has a Snickers and turns into
Marilyn he turns into Marilyn Monroe he
really does yeah so Marilyn Marilyn
Monroe's likeness for a Snickers I
always think that's so [ __ ] weird
when they can bring someone back from
the dead to Shilla product yeah the idea
that she's still doing Snickers
commercial right there
even after you did bring back Elvis for
Carl's jr. commercial yeah it would be
like yeah well I don't want to be
brought back well there was an iconic I
think it was a coke or diet coke
commercial where that was the first one
where they all brought them back yeah
yeah yeah like it was kind of like a
comes alive Boulevard Oh broken drink
yeah sort of thing yeah yeah yeah so
that yeah
but they nailed it so now ya know so now
Marilyn Monroe is like yeah like Mara
Monroe is willing to fire me
this is like a Dafoe Monroe what are you
thinking Snickers well like you've had a
whole year yeah well we're doing this
same bit again I guess how do we make
this bit really insane and not
connective right yeah yeah what's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so as but as somebody who like so the
biggest sporting event in Australia
what is the commercial situation like is
there is it ever anywhere near as
gratuitous as it is here so firstly we
don't have a need to know we don't have
a national sport in the same way as like
the NFL really truly is like that
everyone watches it like everyone
watches the Super Bowl yeah and because
of the way that that day has been you
know we were talking about 100 million
plus people right oh yeah like there is
nothing and it dominates television like
no other shows are doing those sort of
numbers nice so and you know 5 million
dollars for a 30-second spot and all
those sort of things yeah you know so we
don't have anything that will ever the
highest word like the grand finals in
Australia get like 3-4 million people
right maximum okay
and there's two coats that kind of split
it a little bit so you know the the AFL
does better in the Eastern my god the
Victorian and South Australia Western
Australia you know and like the you know
NRL does better in Sydney in Queensland
and you know those sort of places so
whatever like it splits it a little bit
and they don't ever play each other and
no they're different because they're
different cards that'd be great though
but if you could do that you'd have a
Super Bowl you know what that is a
[ __ ] great idea because because it's
even better than the Super Bowl yeah
because they're two different sports
yeah but if you could come up with Oh
Gareth you would you know what that is
that's someone in Australia we've been
too close to see it yeah we needed that
outside hey listen I'm the bird in the
sky baby
we needed a consultant somebody that
kind of like say it from a differently
in the office all right yeah if at the
end of the AFL season where they play
Australian rules football and the NRL
season where they play rugby league that
the winners of both of those
grandfather's play went on yeah two in a
game that was like a combination of a
play a sanctioned combination game yeah
yeah I mean even just like I mean what a
great build-up like coming up with the
rules and great like the negotiation
you're not gonna get it right the first
year there's gonna be a couple off rules
that we won't do that again all right so
one of the AFL guys got killed and right
cool okay obviously we need to limit
those sort of tackles right think we're
gonna side with the Australian rules
football a little more on this one right
yeah yeah but that I mean that would be
great combined so yeah boy cuz I mean I
you know we could find there's a middle
ground there yeah yeah I mean well there
isn't really well that's a bit of a fun
to find that there isn't though right
that's the best thing about it is the
best part that like they really are like
both supreme athletes that wouldn't be
suited like to each other's guy right no
it's like one of those great things of
like find some game in the middle that
really that's a great idea that's like
the way got for the grand finals you
have this super grand photo yeah the
super weird ball versus ball sport
yeah welcome back to sport vs. sport not
sure how this is gonna go at all
I mean that's a good even that's a great
idea that we should have some world
sport versus sport competition ground
yeah where the teams that have won the
individual competitions yeah this is the
World Cup is Super Bowl playing not the
same go they're all playing games that
are half way combinations of the two
sport right yeah you'd have like maybe
the Golden State Warriors in the
basketball could be playing like Steph
Curry is not getting up ladies and
gentlemen is I don't it looks like he's
of the magician's assistant who got cut
into Pete I mean he is his legs are
moving which is a good sign
head still that's very still not
connected to each other obviously
different parts of the field what it's
interesting isn't it like when you talk
about the world's greatest sports people
like I mean who would you consider if I
asked you right now who's the great
sports person in the world who's like
the greatest athlete in the world who
would who would come in the world in the
world so like when I would think of who
is the most the the athlete that I say
the world knows the most almost um or
who do I think
if who do you think the most common
answer to the question because it goes
to then a broader conversation so just
instinctively
so at this point if I say to you who's
the world's greatest athlete who would
you say it is but probably say Messier
but I would also say LeBron James I
would say one of those two I think
probably have the biggest international
brand right buddy but you go in brand
yeah like who's the greatest athlete in
the world like if you I was saying the
greatest athlete if they thought sign
who's the greatest athlete in the world
like if aliens came to us and said who
is your bring us your great assess well
you want your best athlete yeah I don't
know what I spoke about that I think we
speak like that they don't even speak
like that oh wait you guys talk regular
too right oh sorry hello no they talk
regular yeah hey what's up guys they've
been doing the equivalent of shouting
loudly at foreigners we don't talk about
that we speak of this I just assumed you
guys it's oh so sorry here this is
terrible there's a hey how you guys
doing yeah who like who if they were
gonna say who's the world's greatest
sounds like I would honestly I would
probably have to say that I think it
would be LeBron James so could the
argument not be made that LeBron James
is not even the best player in the sport
that he plays at the moment well you
could argue that he's not that he you
could argue that he's not but I would
say is the most athletic player in the
sport right okay yeah I would i I would
think if you're like if you're just
talking about like if America or like
you know like if you did if you had this
great competition that I'm loving where
we're talking about but if you have this
competition where we have to be like we
we don't know exactly what they're gonna
throw at you but you're representing
America I think we would send LeBron
James probably yeah that's you know what
that's pretty good yeah because he does
seem to have like what you'd consider to
be like play in the NFL right yeah he
could play they play in the NFL he could
definitely play a string rules football
he fighted that yeah I think he'd
probably be fine with cricket he's got
good hand-eye coordination be good
imagine yeah baseball I bet he'd be okay
yeah I reckon he'd be fine at baseball
and he clobber Eddie probably competes
really swimming well I can bet he could
[ __ ] swim pretty well yeah I think
yeah the brunt yeah yeah he looks like a
guy who could swim upper body lower body
yeah yeah I would say so yeah
right a horse could he run a horse
crushing horse riding yeah I was gonna
say are we even considering horse
trotting like as being part of this I
mean there's a lot of athletes the [ __ ]
is that doing up there like I guess it's
where you draw the line is like and the
jockeys like boom cuz I mean like elk
weeks LeBron say over like he'd be fast
over short distance but he wouldn't be
good over like so if you're competing
the marathon or whatever LeBron it'd be
no good though like now EBI good in your
endurance sports like a triathlon
wouldn't he be - like you know I don't
know if he be but I mean the he's in
pretty exceptional shape I mean I feel
like you would be able to probably do a
triathlon I started cramping up in a
basketball guy you gotta get your
[ __ ] triathlon fair later on maybe we
shouldn't send LeBron right well I mean
no one's gonna be having any have an IV
with it'd be the perfect all-rounder but
it is it's why like I mean Bruce Jenner
and I say Bruce Jenner because I'm
referring to the former the foot yeah
when when Caitlyn Jenner was Bruce
Jenner yes I won the decathlon at the
Olympics yes and was like though you
know kind of the American Hero yeah and
I've never really understood why
decathlon at the Olympics is not
considered to be the number one sport
yeah you think it should vary yeah
like eight cents if you also made like
we lose something that I like I mean I'd
love to say the same bolt like dominate
like the hundred to two hundred yeah but
I also like to see him compete in the
decathlon yeah I mean like yeah or like
you know because it was always one of
those things really like okay well he's
not the fastest sprue in the world but
he can do high jump javelin and whatever
like quite well yeah like you know
that's an all-around thing oh yeah I
think that's more of us so we should do
we should have like there should be like
a mini Olympics where and this is gonna
sound like that dollar but we should
have like a mini Olympics where you just
nominate these athletes to go and
compete and like these five random games
and I would be more interested how about
this okay I'm in it's the decathlon but
you can choose
with ten only big sports you compete in
to make up your ten events for the
decathlon oh wow so if you're at the
Olympics already so if you qualify in
one sport right right maybe you have to
qualify in like probably minimum like to
sports right well to get an entry into
the decathlon right right so say you
really got 100 and 200 that would be
like or what I can't remember what the
events that are the Catalano but like so
you're really good at like long jump and
shop right so you qualify for both of
those which means you're immediately
into the decathlon right yeah then you
can choose another eight event and it's
where you come ranking right yeah yeah
they give you the points yeah four so it
can be anything it's yeah that is basic
it's like American gladdie
it's a free range decathlon yeah and
what's basically who can do the best at
the Olympics yeah you working appoints
us right yeah who wins the Olympics
right and doesn't really win the
Olympics yeah but these middle tier dath
leets who are pretty good you know could
be like the Olympics could be won the
greatest athlete in the Olympics could
be a guy who's jack of all trades and
masters of none best performance was
like a fourth in gymnast yeah but yeah
really got hurt on the high bars right
yeah but didn't like worst result was
like a 10th in silent yeah I don't know
how to do this properly I mean I love
this look out of just any 10 events it's
a tough one alright saying it's like
ordering food you're like you're ten
yeah because I mean they beat some
strategic advantage that you'd be like I
just think I can pick up some points on
the curling or whatever you're like you
can do the Olympic Winter Sports yeah
yeah yeah
it's an eSport someone check curling
this could be forty thousand dollars
just for one f-fine [ __ ] it
we invented the middle Olympics I was
thinking the other day that's comedy I
think is one of those things where like
there's a range of skills to be a
comedian like or that can be handy being
a comedian right not every comedian has
all those skills and it's not necessary
to have all those skills right
you know I imagined to like I mean I can
never come up with what the exact right
analogy of this is but for example like
to do great impressions yeah is a handy
skill to have as a comedian
you can easily be a comedian without the
skill to do a great impression yeah but
it is something that like you know like
it work it'll work for you right it's a
skill for sure I don't do well in clubs
right and I wonder in this age where
we're becoming more and more sensitive
because like as an Australian comedian
coming to America hearing people do like
a generic Asian voice onstage
sounds really racist to us is that still
happening oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but
here's what I've noticed there's nearly
all voices sound racist now yeah like
like we're getting to the point where
it's hard to do even an impression of
like a cut I mean there's still some
places that you know you you'll always
be able to make fun of the French or
whatever Scotland or whatever where
people don't have specific like negative
stereotypes attached to those yeah but
anytime anyone does like an oppression
these days most of the time it just kind
of sounds racist it's true there have
been times where like day I like on the
dollop there'll be something where it's
like some like it's like a Japanese
person right and you can't it just
doesn't seem right
the minute it's an Irish person you've
opened a can of common oh it's time
Scottish like you're saying French but I
can oh comedy sorry oh yeah but it's
yeah but there's certain accents that I
think you can even do I think like an
Indian accent I feel like you can do in
a non racist way I feel like an Asian
accent is much harder to navigate I
don't know if you can do an Indian
accent and on rice that's why anymore
yeah I guess I mean without like I feel
without lately stumbling into like
seconds which is like sad because yeah
good Indian accent is one of the more
delightful things to hear in the world
it's like a curry right a good curry is
one of the best things in the world I
mean now you've made a Rises I would
never no that's not no I would snow
absolute no I was talking to my nan the
other day not bread my nan nan not that
long ago and this is like how casual
racism can be and like I mean when I
grew up in Australia like yeah because
we would put we play you know cricket
against like India and Pakistan yeah and
Australia also has a huge Indian this
same with what you're about to say I
think is the same with England where my
family like there's a huge yeah keep
going okay so we have a huge Indian
population to the point when like when
during the like the world cover quick at
the one-day World Cup the Indian games
were getting bigger attendances in the
Australian right you know because
there's just so many Indian people you
love they're quicker you know and it was
a so the thing I was gonna start so this
keeps of Indian people there what's the
[ __ ] they are like curry so well is the
we would play against Pakistan the West
Indies we call them the windi's sure we
play guys England now called the palms
obviously mums the palms what's that oh
that's like what Australians called
English people party there was a I'm
gonna google it possibly that computer
just check me over the computer and
although I'll google it because there is
a story behind this because he OMS yeah
P OMS palms
yeah palms and it does mean something
and hopefully it means people of Her
Majesty's service palms here we go let's
say palms Urban Dictionary palm here we
go
palm either comes from prisoner of
mother England oh okay or pomegranate a
reddish colored fruit that Navy of
Australians saw it had a similar color
to the skin of some bits good so one was
a prisoner of mother England so palm
really without the a on the end though a
prisoner of mothering I think obviously
the palm being pomegranate because the
skin is better
yeah that's but nothing's better than
watching like English people fall asleep
on a beach you're like I'll see you
tomorrow lobster man so the beer so that
we call English people palms in
Australia that's how you called them
English the palms you call the New
Zealanders the Kiwis right and that's
because of the kiwi fruit because of the
kiwi bird the qumari bird right the Kiwi
right
yep it's a native bird of New Zealand
sure yeah yeah they have it I think it's
the symbol of a New Zealand the key way
right which is interesting because the
Kiwi is a flightless bird okay I got
Qantas interesting Kiwi [ __ ] yeah well
they're the flying kangaroo Qantas
so again also I don't think any of these
airlines fly a virgin it is weird that
you like willing to go with an airline
that literally as a symbol of a thing
that doesn't fly invented yeah let's get
in the patch
I mean Alyssa could've been a boomerang
this is the same Airport listen get off
the [ __ ] plane thanks for flying
boomerangs thanks for flying boomerang
is have a lovely day the weather is the
same as it was when we took off earlier
but no wonder oh so goddamn cheap
particulars in a circle waiting on my
luck yeah what's going on uh sorry got
the Kiwis the palms we've got the West
Indies who we called the windi's when is
South Africa no boy what do you call
that I don't know we called the South
Africans actually I can't remember what
the South Africa there was a period of
time where they didn't play because of
you know apartheid right off so weak
excused by the way mm-hm I mean it
wasn't their excuse it was the rest of
the world's excuse yeah it was I say we
shouldn't play guys you because you know
we're ready
we're excited right yeah no sorry guys I
don't have any gear the Proteas I
believe these their actual pro tears bro
tears but they're like it's a flower the
pronoun okay does it fly but the two
that I wanted to get to was the
Pakistanis uh-huh who we would call the
package yeah
and the Indians who we would call the
Cory munchers II that one's definitely
yeah but they're at SRI racist but I
can't believe there was a time when we
put because not
like yeah he's a dirty rotten carry
muncher now like oh geez we're gonna be
guys to carry much this tomorrow yeah it
doesn't seem bad well if you think about
it in the NFL we still have a team
called the Redskins which is horribly
offense yeah this week the Redskins
applying the Caravaggio yeah that's what
do you like right you're routing dots or
feathers who we got in this big one
which Indians dear one the Native
American ones
come on curry ranchers I just want the
seeding to be different go ahead I think
that was the same in England though I
was always shocked in England when I
would go there about the casual racism
towards Pakistani and Indian people it
was very strange and prevalent very
prevalent even calling the corner store
like the you know hockey hockey shop or
the [ __ ]
yeah although that's what they would say
though going down the pack yeah go down
the pack you might I always feel bad
because we have one of those little tiny
in my area there's no like convenience
store near we're if there's just one of
those tiny little random you know like
ones particularly that I'm as big here I
don't think but certainly like a big in
Australia where it's just like I'm
certainly a big in the United Kingdom
which is like one of those shops will
you feel like they've just gone and
bought everything from the supermarket
and then put it in their shop is no real
and sits like batteries and bread and
newspapers but then cans of weird things
and like you know sweets from countries
that you haven't really heard of yeah
and like selling a lot of things that
literally say on the package not for
individual resale people they've gone
and bought like a big like thing of
eighteen ice creams and you're not made
to sell them individual resale yeah do
you want it or not literally the whole
store is not for individual resale
individual retail come again thank you I
don't think you ever let us sell Tim
Tims off a plate and what do you want it
or not 40 cents a 40 cents of Tim in 280
if you want the Tam just to it's a
special ronan you get two for the price
of a tam so there used to be the guy say
this is the one that's just walking
distance or in the house and you only go
there I will go there sometimes
newse boba yes if you're desperate for
milk or like cigarettes right like you
know a Sunday morning can of coke you
know that's a like but really it's it's
just for a poppin
well it's pretty much that thing of
going I am so hungover or whatever right
that I cannot take the five minutes of
extra effort it would take to go to
somewhere that'll actually have the
things I want right so this will do yeah
you'll do a friend this will do I'm
gonna go into the not the end of it
lucky me oh yeah I'm not buying fruit
there but this is not a place I've ever
known fruit there's still advertising
[ __ ] on the sign that they haven't sold
for like 20 years that's like it's one
of those places so I go in there and we
used to call it they used to be like
that it used to be like the version
there was like an Asian version of like
The Soup Nazi guy ran it so the other
reason you'd never go there was that he
just seemed really really angry at you
right every time you went into the shop
well he was probably stressed out about
the resale police coming it's not fine
that's what he probably thought I was
from the reseller place take the tip
temp for free not a sharper display
display it's an artistic expression of
capitalism can I see some identification
sir so he was angry and so he got into
the habit of saying if I was going down
I go I do on every anything from the I'm
gonna go and visit the angry Asian right
and he became in our mind this like
comic book character right
the angry Asian and but it wasn't rare
but it wasn't racist now it was a
description I think that's a fair
description I think that is more that to
me is rooted so much more in comedy than
it is I mean that's that doesn't seem
like a rush it was on the I'm you know I
wasn't like I was like calling him the
angry Asian to Omega phone down the
street yeah all to his face
yeah I wasn't like what's up I hey
what's up angry how you doing doc
they just say the guy at the convenience
store you know what you don't want to
make him angry he's always angry
actually he's always angry that's a
secret you say Cray disease all
he's always angry he's always Asian to
things like three things you know things
I guarantee you about this individual
yeah
and he was never not angry and he was
never not Asian Yeah right
and I would go down there and I would
try to crack through to like I was like
I'm gonna get because I was always my
mission like I was I always had this
kind of fantasy that one day I would
like go back to the house and I'd be
like guess what guess who had a little
breakthrough down at the corner store
today I'm gonna tell you something
he's still Asian but my man's happy
right we got a happy Asian I wasn't even
aiming for happy I just I mean normal
normal an Asian person
I mean apathetic anything other than
angry yeah like zooming a pathetic
pathetic Asian take whatever right oh
okay buddy
right despondent Asian I'd be happy with
everything yeah
confused Asian do I work here to you
right yeah if you like just a range of
emotion show me something yeah all I
would get was anger from this guy yeah
so never happened then I went away for
like I was on the road for like 18
months or whatever and I've gone back
home and it's a long time since you know
I've I've been down there and I'd kind
of I don't even really go down there
that regularly anyway but I just had
started to have this like longing you
know I was like I want to go on I want
to go and visit angry Asian you wanted
to just see him you didn't have a
product I didn't have you didn't need
any apples or just a razor that was sold
from a pack of eighteen not knowing I I
just wanted to say the aggregation and I
went down there and I walked through the
door he wasn't angry anymore
really and it was just like it was one
of those moments where I was like you
know what that's what you try to get him
angry yes
I have to go buy a gun I want to see my
old friend again get out of this star
there he is
hello old friend so I felt really good
about that and I was kind of like are
nice it feels like things are going
better and he's in his life or whatever
yeah and and then I've gone back and
taught Amy this and she goes oh you know
that's that's not the same guy and I was
like I will say this in my defense so
this is like literally this is one of
those times where I wonder if so
obviously the cliche being you know
youth that's like you think that this
person is that person because they're
both Asian you know like that yet they
all look the same to you right this is
one of those moments please what I need
to say and I know this sounds
self-serving I think we're all very
excited to hear what's about to happen
they really do leave you if you did not
know like I mean these guys literally do
it might be like a franchise store that
you don't know about and they can just
sort of swap in and out versions of the
similar man you I feel like maybe it's a
family thing okay like I feel like maybe
in the business his balance son finally
took over Oh might be the next
generation yeah which is always good Oh
angry eyes and jr. the next generation
all right that's pretty good I'm hang on
what time is it let's see what I can say
oh yeah okay so we got some time why
don't we have another little break you
can make your salad oh great if you'd
like sure and I made a salad and then we
can leave lock the other squeeze one
more in great all right Gareth Reynolds
I Reynolds Gareth on all the socials yes
the dollop yes point versus point yes
live versions of the dollop in April
17th 18th New York in Chicago
at the Belleville house in Bell House in
New York and then could whole Lincoln
Hall in Chicago which is a great place
and I know that we have heaps of
listeners in I don't know how many we
have in New York but I know that we have
heaps in Chicago because yeah I'm out
and saw my shows when I was in town so
please go and say he's great the dollar
yeah I was just at Lincoln Hall that
theater it's it's [ __ ] great was it
right place yeah so I'm excited all
right
it that is not where now Lincoln didn't
get shot at the Lincoln Theatre right
now what are the odds
poor bastard I was at the Lincoln hole
and I was in the John Wilkes Booth
that's why Wilkes Booth gets upset he
was like that was my booth
it said John Wilkes right above it and
not a lot of people know - it took two
shots once through the top of the hat
and then once to the bottom - I say
because that [ __ ] tall six shot yeah
five yeah just hat like they could
eventually took the hat off to inspect
it he was like there it is there's this
shot finally damn that took forever
hopefully I can hit this is my last
bullet they had seen better days
my shofar at will is on sale at the
moment by the time you hear this I don't
know where I'll be but it's on sale all
around Australia you've either it's
either been to where you are or it's
coming to where you are if you live in
the major capital cities
you're really excluding Tasmania sorry
about that toes right now
I'd love to come to Tasmania people
often say come and test mine yeah you'd
sell it all your shows and I'm like no
actually I wouldn't
but why how do you know there's not
enough people there we've been before
story checks out
believe me if we would sell it all my
shows I would come yeah it's pretty much
a general rule of thumb yeah if there is
anywhere I am like a big enough act that
I will sell out all good news I'll be
there I guess what we'll add some more
shows
I'll show you who kids are I've had so
many shows people will not want me there
as they come and say that big live toe
pop show at the Melbourne International
Comedy Festival April the nights of
Daniel sauce Justin Hamilton John Digges
Charlie and myself of course loads of
other guests to be added as we go for
that show so it's not on sale yet but
you can op you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
in LA that is the wait between the two
Coachella weekend so if you happen to be
an Australian who's traveling over for
Coachella or in you in LA
during that wake and that would be a fun
show to come and see so there you go all
right we'll talk to you soon